[Music]
a district court judge denied an effort
by president trump's campaign and the
nevada republican party
to delay the county of mail ballots in
clark county
thank you for joining us on 8 news now
at 6 30 i'm brian loftis
and i'm denise valdez so in that lawsuit
which was filed back in late october
attorneys for the trump campaign claimed
it was impossible to accurately check
signatures
and verify every ballot clark county
elections chief joe gloria testified
that not using the signature scanner
would just require a massive overhaul
the trump campaign also alleged they
were not able to record while they were
observing ballot counting
clark county argued that observers are
allowed but recording
violates nevada law the request to stop
mail ballot county was denied by a
carson city judge
this morning talked with nevada trump
campaign co-chair and former attorney
general adam laxalt
who is leading the charge on these
lawsuits and he says he is fighting for
transparency for all voters you have
nearly 500 thousand mail-in ballots
coming through the clark county system
a machine is approving 30 to 40 percent
of those
and if it's approved it counts so no
human being touches those
and then it goes to workers
and it's a hallmark of our system
now a third lawsuit filed by the trump
campaign had a hearing today and that
lawsuit seeks to get information about
signature checkers such as their
political official their political
affiliations clark county says the
election panels are all bipartisan
though
laxalt says if necessary they are
prepared to take that fight to the
supreme court
a spokesperson for the clark county said
in a statement the county was pleased
with the decision to halt the second
lawsuit
they released a statement that said in
part we fully agree with the judge and
appreciate his clear rulings on the
matters raised
this is the busiest time of the year for
the election department
and we are glad to have another baseless
lawsuit dismissed so quickly
nevada attorney general aaron ford also
releasing a statement saying in part
today's ruling makes clear that there is
proper procedure to observe an election
that even the president must follow and
it's most certainly a victory for the
constitutional rights of all nevadans